- Usually I'll tell you
about something or someone
I'm obsessed with at
this point in the show.
Well, today it's my band who's obsessed.
Their obsession has taken many forms.
Lifeguard, Knight Rider.
That's right.
German icon, but he's known
globally as one name, people.
The Hoff, give it up for David Hasselhoff!
(alternative band music plays)
(audience cheers and claps)
- It's the Hoff.
How are you doing?
- I'm doing fantastic.
What, who's your audience?
Hello everybody, from.
- Say hello y'all.
I forget how, you're so tall.
Literally every time I'm like, okay.
It's like being around Blake.
So who's the biggest fan in the band?
- [Band Member] Its Jason.
- Jason is the biggest fan.
I do remember we were on tour in Germany.
I believe Berlin.
And y'all went to the museum.
What was that like?
- Oh yeah, it was incredible.
I mean, I've been a fan.
I mean, everybody grew
up with Knight Rider
and I didn't have the
heights but I had some hair,
and my first car was a black Ford Probe
'cause I couldn't afford the Trans-Am.
But I mean, I knew he was an actor
but I had no idea his musical catalog
until we were all listening
to songs on the bus one night
and I think it was Lester that pulled out
one of his rock songs.
I was like, "Oh my gosh, he can sing."
- Oh my gosh.
- Then we found out about the museum.
Went there, and while we were there,
they had all these signs that he was part
of the fall of the Berlin wall.
Thought it was a joke,
went home and looked it up.
And it's real.
Like he played a huge part in that.
So it just keeps on going.
So I'm the fan.
- Wait, is that why the
museum is in Berlin?
- The museum is in Berlin
because I sang to a million
people on new year's Eve.
And I sang,
♪ I've been looking for freedom. ♪
And in east Germany, which
wasn't free at that point,
that's all they knew.
And they knew that I was
the guy from Knight Rider
who sang about freedom.
So I went and sang above a million people
from East and West Germany.
And that's why I became famous in Germany.
And then I've been going back
and selling a few records
and then they ended up
making a museum about me.
- I know, but that's got
to be a crazy moment.
You're standing in the center of people
that literally cannot cross.
The energy of that and all of
them singing the same song,
that must have been really powerful.
- It was unbelievable because
I went behind the wall
with a special that
National Geographic did.
And I went back and I
met people who escaped
and I said, "How do you know me?"
And they went, "I've been
looking for freedom."
- Oh my gosh!
- And they couldn't sing the next line,
because they were taught Russian
instead of English in school.
And it was really tough over there.
- Music is powerful.
- It was really tough.
- I do love that music is powerful.
It can unite people.
I believe in that.
It sounds cheesy.
I really do truly believe that.
So wait, do you have something
planned with my band today?
I heard that you did,
and I'm very excited.
- Yeah, you're missing
something in the show.
And I think that-
- What?
A theme song, you don't have a theme song.
- Oh, I don't have a-
- We have worked up a
few theme songs for you.
- All right.
Can I hear, you want to tell me about one?
Maybe sing one or?
I don't know.
- Let's just sing it.
Lets sing it.
Okay, let's do it.
You have now given me permission
to use this as my theme.
I'm just saying. (laughs)
'Cause I love it.
And I'm excited.
- Hit it, Jason.
♪ It's time time to watch some Kelly. ♪
♪ Kelly on the telly ♪
♪ Its the Kelly Clarkson show ♪
- You talk about that ending.
(audience cheers)
All right, all right.
I liked it.
I felt the vibe.
- What do you think?
What do you think?
I love it.
I have a feeling I'm
gonna want all of them.
- It's for sale.
I'm gonna literally have,
I want all of them too like
for different people that call.
Because I feel like you have
a few and I want all of them.